What's up guys.
Jared here and today we're talking about
one of the best anime of the year,
season two of my hero academia,
my hero academia.
Ask some serious questions about
heroism,
namely our all of our heroes full of
woken list.
Wisecrack quick take on my hero academia
season two and of course spoilers ahead
for those uninitiated.
Here's a quick recap.
Mindoro academia takes place in a world
war 80% of people manifest some sort of
superpower or quirk and being a hero has
finally become a full time job.
Canela cut staff in [inaudible] 89 can
you kind of assume road
and eight glamorous one at that middle
school or mid Doria is Zuku yearns to be
like his idol.
Be Hero.
All Mike but unfortunately is cordless.
But after demonstrating his selflessness
to all might madorie heir receives his
very own powers from his hero.
Done a show with me.
She mean you seemed you to walk us snow.
We got it.
Good at the dock,
kimmy.
No,
been through your uncle too.
After a year of training,
memoria enrolls in the exclusive high
school for will be heroes UAA academy.
At the end of season one,
he and his classmates come face to face
with some real bad guys.
The League of villains led by sugar,
Rocky Tamara only for all might to save
the day.
Now,
there are a lot of great moments in
season two,
but where this question of what it means
to be a hero really comes to the fore is
during the stain art class,
President Eda 10 ya'll learns that his
brother has been attacked by the hero
killer stain stain.
Believe that today's heroes are more
concerned with their own image than
actually doing good.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
determined to get revenge eda then
interns with the less than prestigious
normal hero in order to find stain.
Wild Memoria Doria is stuck well with
this guy and as sugar rocky on leashes,
a hoard of biologically engineered super
villains on the city.
Eda memoria and fellow classmate Tota
Roci managed to converge on stain and
capture him.
The stain arch raises the question what
causes our obsession with heroism?
According to philosopher Ernest Becker,
the desire to be a hero is innate.
It's the desire to be the very best at
something and ultimately to be
remembered and thereby transcend death.
But most of us aren't.
Heroes were Jerry's or some mentos at
best.
Instead,
Becker tells us that we redirect this
desire into society or what he calls
cultural hero systems.
Bummed.
You're not all might.
That's okay.
Feel special because in genomes,
younger brother interns at your hero
agency sad.
You're not always saving the day.
Who Cares?
You can still feature on a TV talk show
panel because of your ridiculous
costume.
It's this kind of hero worship which
stain opposes instead of believing that
Hiro's must epitomize self sacrifice.
[inaudible] you doing [inaudible] sold
off all [inaudible] here you she don't
even know.
Hygiene,
sugar,
bodily organ music.
She's a good mother.
Same rejects a society that treats
heroes like celebrities paying them for
capturing villains and allowing them to
use their status for lucrative side
hustles.
Same believes that being a superhero
with an asterisk isn't being a superhero
at all.
And this argument isn't all that crazy.
And in fact,
mirrors and idea that philosopher slash
senior men's models,
Jacques Derrida dubbed unconditional
hospitality.
To Derrida.
Unconditional hospitality is a pure,
unbounded kindness and generosity to
others.
A law without law,
as he confusingly called it to dairy
dot.
True absolute hospitality cannot be
imposed upon by rules,
duties,
or laws,
whether they be legal,
cultural,
or even moral.
Otherwise it stops being unconditional.
As one thinker put it,
the law of hospitality is absolute in
that it requires one to give all one has
to another without asking any questions
and posing any restrictions or requiring
any compensation.
If we apply Derrida's logic to my hair
academia,
the heroes are only acting out a
conditional hospitality.
How you look over your care team may
accuse you of doing the bowl game though
he acts Sonia Super.
So I'll say [inaudible].
You hope this is particularly the case
with Eda who is so wrapped up in his
desire for revenge that he forgets what
it means to be a hero.
Putting others first.
And Dakota Hito [inaudible] will know to
know Tom,
any wholesale when eat a stumbles upon
stain attacking native eva,
is it really coming to the rescue
instead,
he's implicitly making natives rescue
contingent on him getting what he wants,
killing stain and saying the perceptive
slasher tells it as it is.
Does Dad oh you to a muzzle Tuscan.
Here's the Kodo clady meets a toast
credo.
Say [inaudible] she cuddles [inaudible]
feudal kind of tumor.
By the way,
this white team was really awesome.
Probably one of the best of the season
and if you want to see it broken down by
one of our friends,
check out jeff over at mother's
basement.
He just dropped a video analyzing all
the things that make this fight scene
incredible.
So check them out in the link in the
description.
You won't regret it.
Anyway,
this all goes to show what makes
medallia and all mites special.
They're unwavering adherence to
unconditional hospitality.
In fact,
it's Madorie as willingness to sacrifice
himself for others,
even without a quirk that originally
drew all might the him,
you.
And over the course of seasons one and
two,
we see memorial putting himself on the
line over and over again,
whether it's leaping into the fray
against the League of villains,
when all my team's down for the count or
arriving last minute to save Edo Stain.
Hell Madora can even use one for all
without essentially shattering the bones
in his body,
but that's never stopped him.
Of course,
stain recognizes this trait.
Memoria initially sparing him
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible],
but [inaudible] is only a pale
comparison of what stain really wants to
fight the symbol of peace himself.
After stain saves Memoria from being
abducted,
he declares Jamie,
no,
no shale.
That's right.
Staying motivated to make a more just
society will only let himself be brought
down by eight true hero.
The embodiment of unconditional
hospitality all might.
Now stain isn't the main villain of my
hero academia,
but his impact has really felt in the
seasons.
Concluding episode,
what starts as a day off from a
Dorianne,
his classmates ends with Memoria being
briefly held captive by sugar rocky.
Now sugar rocky is royally pissed at
stain for scorning him and drawing so
much attention.
Martin Davis,
so good [inaudible].
What sugar,
rocky can't see is how he's different
than stain,
but asthma.
Doria explains staying stands for
something.
Costa Rica cost is on tonight.
I know he does it on him though it does
go to the mall.
He Sony,
Datto.
Now to end this,
we're going to invoke a little more
becker here.
Remember those cultural hero systems in
society?
He said they were all based on the
denial of death.
The reason why we strive to get a raise,
fall in love or even start a family is
because even if we're only side
characters and then pcs were desperately
trying to feel special in our little
corner of the universe and be remembered
to becker though society would crumble
if we ever realized how little our
deaths actually mean to the unfeeling
universe.
As such,
we have to desperately protect these
fragile artificial hero systems that
make up society.
This issue of confronting death becomes
even more pronounced in the world of my
hero academia where your everyday
citizens mortality constantly put on
display when supervillains can appear
and kill hundreds in an instant.
How does your average person go about
living their life?
Just as in our lives,
people can only create meaning by
building up images of heroes and for
shipping and specifically the symbol of
peace himself.
All might as shooter rocky releases
Madorie.
Yet he realizes he's been driven by an
ideal all along.
Destroying the symbol that gives society
eats
quite sort of [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
So what do you think?
Wise cracking,
what does it mean to be a hero or they
really the glue that binds society
together?
Let us know by dropping a line in the
comment section and as always want to
rewatch my hero academia with a whole
new outlook or just check it out again
before season three comes out,
head on over to crunchy roll.com/wise
crack and while you're there,
sign up for a free month of crunchy roll
premium crunchy roll premium is a great
way to get unlimited access to tons of
awesome animate.
They've got hundreds of series for you
to watch with access as soon as one hour
after they air on TV.
In Japan you can catch shows like dragon
ball,
super burrito food wars and my favorite
full metal alchemist brotherhood plus
tons more.
Whatever you're looking for.
Crunchy roll is giving wisecrack fans a
free month of crunchy.
We'll premium to watch all the anime you
could possibly want ad free and
inglorious 10 ADP and on over the
country.
roll.com/wise
crack to start your free trial and to
check it out.
Thanks to crunchy roll for sponsoring
this video,
and we've got tons more videos planned
for you,
including ones on the prestige event.
Jellyin archer and tons more to be sure
to subscribe if you haven't already,
and as always,
catch all next time he's.